Given the astounding success
of The Last of Us, hopefully,
this gives studios a much better outlook
on wanting to do high-quality video game
adaptations. And ones that are actually
faithful to the source material. That’s
the major distinction because there’s been
a lot so far that don’t follow the source
material at all *cough* Halo *cough* and The
Last of Us is proof that there is a ton of
unmined potential within the video game sphere
because we are basically just getting started.
For the first game on this list, since The Last of
Us has had groundbreaking success, it only makes
sense to adapt God of War. Initially, upon writing
this I didn’t even know that Amazon acquired the
rights to do an adaptation of God of War back
in December 2022. There haven’t really been
any updates about it, so I’ll still go into
why this could make such a great adaptation,
even though it’s announced. Now this would be a
very challenging game to adapt given how huge the
scale of it is. Along with the budget probably
needing to be massive. Out of all the studios
to acquire it though, Amazon would most likely
be willing to write a blank check for the show
given that The Rings of Power costed over
a billion dollars. However, if they didn’t
want to casually drop another billion dollars,
you could start the show at God of War 2018.
The budget will still need to be pretty large,
but at least the story will be more manageable
to tell at a slightly smaller scale in comparison
to the first three games. Given that at its core,
it’s primarily a father and son adventure. So
that's a pretty easy story to tackle for a show
format. Kratos and Atreus are complex characters
and their rich dynamic will anchor down the story.
Kratos learns to become a better father and opens
up to his son, while Atreus learns to become more
mature and to be more like a warrior. There’s a
strong progression for both of these characters
so every dialogue scene they have together should
be very engaging. That’s one thing that most video
game adaptations require. If it doesn’t have a
strong base story with great characters, then
it would be really hard to translate it over to
shows and movies. Like the biggest example of this
is Doom. There really isn’t much of a story or
characters in Doom, and is predominantly carried
by its gameplay. It does have some cool background
lore, but you also need a great plot. For shows
and movies, you can’t just have non-stop action
with barely any dialogue. Because if you do that,
you won’t be able to form an attachment to
the characters and the audience will slowly
stop caring about the narrative. A good story
makes you care about the action and without one,
you won’t be invested or have any stakes in
the action. So on the other side of this coin,
you have God of War. Two loveable characters
who go on a fun journey across the realms. Any
action along the way is investing because you
like the characters and you want to see them
achieve their goal. I just wanted to quickly go
over that, because I won’t be including games
that are solely based on good gameplay. Going
into how much meat God of War has to offer,
you can easily do a whole season per game. At
least pertaining to the last two God of Wars. I
think there’s enough there and even though there
are some repetitive sections within those games,
you can cut them out and tighten up the pace for
the narrative. I also think that choosing God of
War 2018 as a starting point will make Kratos
an even more intriguing character given how
mysterious his past is. Because throughout the
game the writers allude to what happened in the
past. So if anything, skipping the first three
games won’t hinder the overall story because
God of War 2018 essentially hits the restart
button. You can start it at the very beginning
and go into the tragedy of Kratos’ origin, but
you’ll have to make some heavy changes to the
story because I’d assume viewers won’t want to
watch Kratos go to the underworld three separate
times. Out of all of the adaptations I’ll be
going into, this is at the top of my list.
Another dream come true would be a proper
adaptation of Halo. Since the Paramount + show
doesn’t exist to me. Now this is much harder
material to adapt in comparison to other games
given that Master Chief is kind of just a
vessel for the player. He has extremely light
characterization and only Halo 4 really makes
an effort to humanize him. So telling his story
if anything kind of feels like a trap. You’d
either have to make major changes to the source
material to make Master Chief more of a character
similar to the Paramount Plus show so that you can
sympathize and relate to him. But also not like
the show where they make him overly emotional,
he barely has his helmet on, and they even give
him nude scenes. Or if you don’t make any changes
to Master Chief, you have a main protagonist that
barely talks. I keep seeing people say that they
would love a show with this faithfulness to
Chief, but again, without a proper character
to be attached to who barely speaks or emotes,
then the story will have a hard time operating.
Games can get away with this because it’s more
objective based and you become the character. For
shows and movies, we witness the story without
having any input. Since Master Chief would be
very difficult to adapt without ruining him,
I would recommend adapting a story within the
Halo universe that doesn’t involve Chief, or at
least doesn’t make him the main character. That
may be a controversial opinion, but that also
seems to be the most realistic and easiest of
the options. There’s also a lot of material to
choose from that doesn’t even include Master
Chief, but I’ll only look at the existing games.
Currently the most adaptable and that also happens
to be one of the best stories is Halo: Reach.
This is an outstanding setting and witnessing
a society collapse from an alien invasion is
awesome. Halo: Reach also has a good roster of
characters. Now they aren’t as rich as the main
characters in The Last of Us and God of War, but
it wouldn’t betray the source material to expand
upon these characters. They’re all pretty distinct
and varied, so you’ll be able to make for some
good pairings throughout the miniseries. Which
is what I think Halo: Reach will fit the best as.
Each mission would lend pretty well to a separate
episode given that they are consistently
changing settings. And in each episode,
they can spend time developing a certain character
within the squad with the main character. Also,
for the main character, he doesn’t have much of a
personality and is even more of a vessel for the
player than Master Chief, so you’ll have to change
him and make him an actual character. You can lean
into how he’s pitched as in the game in which
he’s a lone wolf with a mysterious past. This
could naturally offer as a point of conflict
between the main character and the team, and
through the story he learns the value of teamwork
and is reinvigorated by the camaraderie of his new
family. Thus changing him into a character with
more heart and someone with warmth. At first,
he could be doubtful about the effectiveness of
his team and attempts to get things done on his
own in a selfish manner and is more closed
off. Then through the course of the show,
all these negative aspects are peeled away through
different selfless and kind acts made by his team.
I think this could offer a solid character arc
for Noble Six and can easily add a deeper layer
to him. That and you don’t have to make him the
main character since he’ll inherently be a bit
unlikable towards the beginning. If you went with
this pitch. So instead, you could mostly focus on
the squad as a whole, while slowly pivoting
towards Noble Six as being the main point of
view who is slowly winning the hearts of the
audience. The overall story arc for Halo Reach
is pretty great and I would go into more depth
about it, but that would be going into spoilers,
and I kind of want to stay away from them
in this video since I’ll be touching on
a wide array of games. But the story acts as
a mad dash to save humanity and the squad we
follow are integral in that goal and the actions
they make carry a massive amount of weight. This
can easily be a very epic, fun, and emotional
journey carried out by this lovable squad of
spartans. It’s just really depressing that this
probably won’t come to fruition for a while given
that Paramount + is doing their own show and
that doesn’t even follow the source material.
Dead Space. This is a game that I’m genuinely
surprised hasn’t been adapted into a horror
movie yet, or even hearing any development around
a possible movie. Because between everything on
this list, this is probably the easiest material
to adapt because of the simple premise of the
game. This crew responds to a distress signal
in space and they are met with nightmarish and
eldritch horrors and the crew then has to
escape. The premise in of itself is perfect
for a movie and the atmosphere in the game is
extremely immersive. The dilapidating interiors,
blood-soaked and terrifying displays of gore and
body horror strewn throughout the environment,
creepy lighting and atmosphere that
always hammers home a feeling of dread,
this is literally a perfect horror environment.
In the hands of a competent horror director, this
should be a surefire hit. Even though the premise
itself isn’t entirely original, the designs of
the monsters and how everything operates is very
intriguing. Like the mystery behind the Marker and
how it affects people would constantly keep a hook
in the audience. Along with it potentially being
cool visually how the filmmakers would portray
the hysteria induced by the Marker. As for how the
story of the game translates to a movie, it should
definitely be cut down because the game is mostly
a string of objectives of repairing the Ishimura.
Having to repair basically the entire ship was
mostly a story mechanic to artificially elongate
the game. This is fine for the game because they
keep introducing new gameplay elements to keep
things fresh and interesting. But for a movie,
you need to keep the narrative moving at
a satisfying pace. So any filmmaker would
definitely need to cut it down and from there, you
could cherry-pick the many horror set pieces from
the game. That and the climax is pretty insane
so the ending should definitely still be great
for the movie. In terms of budget, it should
definitely be pretty manageable because most of
the game takes place in closed interiors. Meaning
that you could shoot all of this on enclosed sets
on a soundstage. The amount of VFX shouldn’t
be too crazy and I’d much prefer to see some
practical necromorphs. If any filmmaker were to
go with solely VFX necromorphs then that would
be extremely saddening. But overall, I’d assume
this will probably be adapted soon especially
since the popularity around the game has surged
from the outstanding reception of the remake.
Bioshock. Now this game has been blueballing
gamers because there has been news about a movie
for this game ranging back to pre-2010. Studios
were scared to make the movie because making
a very high-budget R-rated movie seemed like a
guaranteed flop. However, a year and a half ago,
it was announced that this game is actually
being developed by Netflix in a partnership
with 2k games. It’s being directed by Francis
Lawrence who directed the last 3 Hunger Games and
I am Legend. So it’s in the hands of a competent
director and the studio that developed the game is
involved. The only thing about this adaptation
though and why I’m including this is that we
haven’t received much updates about this project
and that makes me worried given what happened in
the past. But going into why Bioshock would make
a magnificent adaptation is because it checks off
a lot boxes. The world of Rapture is incredibly
immersive and is a constant visual feast. The
underwater city lends itself to so many unique and
cool setpieces of withering structures that have
so much environmental storytelling. The entire
background behind the architecture is just so
intriguing and so is all of the story surrounding
it. This could lead to such a thought-provoking
script because the world is constantly oozing
with so much subtext about what happened to this
dystopian society. It has engaging themes like
that of class, inequality, unchecked capitalism,
and abuse of power leading to the fall of this
city. There’s also a lot of vibrant and unhinged
characters throughout this world and given
that there’s so much dialogue communicated
over a radio, there should never be any down
moments within the script. Along with there
being an outstanding twist towards the end of the
game that completely shatters your perception of
the story. Then there’s also the brilliant
designs of the augmented humans like slicers
and big daddys that would be so cool to see done
in live action. Really every aspect about the game
carried over into a movie or mini-series setting
will be an instant classic. So hopefully Netflix
actually commits to making this project and gives
them a big enough budget. Because another thing
that makes me really excited about the Netflix
adaptation is that it’s being written by the
writer of Blade Runner 2049. That pace and overall
aesthetic from that movie would fit perfectly in
Bioshock, and if they somehow got Roger Deakins
as the cinematographer then I’d probably pass out.
Resident Evil 7. This would be a pretty simple
adaptation honestly and the main reason why I’m
choosing the 7th entry is because A. It’s not an
overly complex story and is mainly about surviving
this crazy family, and B. There’s been a lot of
failed adaptations for the first couple of games,
so I’d like to see them try some different
games in the franchise. I admittedly haven’t
played Resident Evil 4 yet and really want to,
so I wouldn’t be surprised if that would also
make for a great movie as well. But for Resident
Evil 7, making it a pure horror movie of Ethan
slowly trying to overcome this psychotic
hillbilly family with powers would make
for a riveting ride. It’s also extremely similar
to the original Texas Chainsaw Massacre so the
story already should function within a movie or
mini-series format. If it were in a mini-series
format, you can have each episode where Ethan
overcomes one of the members of the family and
thus becomes more hardened as a character. Or
if it were a movie, you can condense down some
of the setpieces a bit and make it a perfect 2
hours. Like ideally probably cut out the whole
boat sequence which felt weird and try to tackle
the same story revelation in a different manner. I
would go into that more, but I’m refraining from
going into spoilers. Talking about it vaguely
though, the general background to this story
and how this family ended up the way they did,
is really a tragedy and it uncovers a whole nother
layer to the story that gives it a lot of depth,
and doesn’t just make this family a
bunch of psychos. It makes them a lot
more sympathetic and by the end of the game,
you kind of just feel bad for them. The main
character would probably need a little bit more
characterization, but at the end of the day,
it is really a story of survival and that
always is a great time for horror movies.
Overwatch. I’m honestly really surprised that
I even have to include this game because you’d
assume that Blizzard would have made an animated
movie or series by this point. Like the game has
been out for seven years. God damn, I feel
old now. However, as I was making this video,
Blizzard did release an animated miniseries
for Overwatch. Although it’s extremely short
in length, and for that runtime, it was
pretty good. So the question stands,
why the hell isn’t Blizzard contracting studios
to make longer-form content? It’s definitely
not a money issue since Blizzard as a company is
reeling in 1 to 2 Billion dollars of net income a
year. So greenlighting an animated series or movie
shouldn’t be that big of a deal. And if anything,
it would just make them more money. It’s maddening
because the possibilities are truly endless and
you could go into so many outstanding directions
for an Overwatch series. You could go the Arcane
route and make a rich and grounded drama and go
into the complexities of the world and select
characters. You could go down a more anthology
route where each episode follows one or a few
heroes as they carry out their most important
missions. Or you could even make the show like
that amazing and epic Clone Wars show back
in the day, where you have massive battles
with a huge scale. Literally, the possibilities
are endless and I’d assume you’d love to watch
any of the three pitches I mentioned. So the
fact that we really have none of that is truly
heartbreaking from the untapped potential. There
are so many cool and interesting characters that
I would love to learn more about. The game only
scratches the surface for these characters in
terms of development and it feels like fans have
been blueballed for so long in terms of getting
to know them more. For me personally, I only know
the surface level for each of the characters in
Overwatch and I would love to get a deep dive and
learn much more about them. That and the world
of Overwatch is definitely intriguing enough to
carry a show. So when Cuphead of all IPs gets 3
seasons before Blizzard does practically anything
with Overwatch is really depressing. I don’t know
what the hell management is doing over there and
surely all the money they’re milking out of their
players with absurd shop prices and battle passes
can give them enough money for a proper show.
Red Dead Redemption 2. Out of Rockstar’s
catalogue, this seems like the best pick. Which
isn’t downplaying GTA5 which could also make for
an interesting mini-series, but I think the story
for Red Dead Redemption 2 is a bit better. A group
of outlaws who are all colorful and sympathetic in
their own way would make for a fun perspective
to follow for a big sprawling adventure. They’re
all essentially antiheroes and morally complex
characters who aren’t just good or bad and that
makes riveting subjects in my opinion. Along with
the deep dynamics and synergies between all of
them. The main reason why I’m bringing up Red Dead
Redemption 2 besides the fact that it has a great
story, is that Westerns in general have really
fallen off over the years. Which is kind of sad,
to be honest. They used to be so dominant back
in the day and there are only a small handful
of good Westerns that have come out in the last
10 years. So it would be really exciting to see
a big return to this genre that would ideally
be followed by a big budget. Which this would
also kind of be a first in that we don’t have that
many other high-budget western period shows. The
only two that come to mind is Deadwood and Hell on
Wheels, so there is basically no competition right
now for this area and I would love the variety.
That and I think Red Dead Redemption 2 could
find a really good balance between story/character
development and action. Given that there are many
action setpieces in the game that could easily be
cherry-picked. But yeah, RDR2 seems like a pretty
easy layup to the point that I’m surprised
no studios have taken an interest in it yet.
Little Nightmares. Now this may be a surprise
to you that I’m including this game and some
of you may not have heard of Little Nightmares.
It’s an indie horror game in which you have to
navigate a hostile, malformed, and dark world with
horrors awaiting around every corner. The monster
designs in this game are really unsettling
and plays into the childlike perspective of
exaggerated horrors. The world is extremely
harsh and foreboding for you as a player and
there is so much detail within the world that
that is the main driver for storytelling. Every
environment tells a deeply tragic and dark
story that as you progress through the game,
it’s like you are slowly piecing together a
jigsaw puzzle as to what happened here. There’s
also no dialogue within the game so it makes the
mystery of this world that much more alluring. So
right away I think this would make for a perfect
stop-motion horror adventure. The crazy thing is
that this project was actually being developed
and it was oddly enough being spearheaded by
Anthony and Joe Russo. I honestly just chanced
upon the project as I was looking through their
IMDB page. But the Little Nightmares adaptation
was going to be directed by the legendary Henry
Selick who directed both The Nightmare Before
Christmas and Coraline. So the potential behind
this project was huge and it’s really depressing
that the project ended up fizzling out. Because
this world fits perfectly for that kind of dark
stop-motion aesthetic. Along with the story
actually being pretty riveting. Especially
for the second game in which there are some
pretty big and surprising twists. So yeah, I
just wanted to call out this game since the
world is so immersive and would be a really fun
adventure if the right talent wanted to make it.
Gears of War. Similar to Bioshock, it feels like
Gears of War has been in a perpetual development
hell for adaptations. And again like Bioshock,
it seems that Netflix is stepping in and making
it a reality. The main reason why I’m including
this game is that I really love the premise of
the game and it could make for a cool gritty,
sci-fy, war epic. These kind of genre blends
are really rare and that is why I’m craving it so
much and so are you most likely. Just like Halo,
fighting a war against an alien-like threat
where we are actively learning about them
as the story goes on, makes the threat much
more terryfing. Along with there being cool
reveals for different enemy types throughout
the story to keep things fresh and exciting.
There’s so many fun and cool setpieces through
the initial trilogy to the point that they can
definitely do a movie for each game. Like
I would love to see the worm setpiece from
the second game without going into spoilers.
Then from a story and character perspective,
you can definitely create a pretty solid pace
since every character is pretty varied and iconic.
I’d love some actual sit-down scenes with these
characters since we don’t really get that from
the games. All the dialogue is done while they
are walking through the world when they aren’t
engaged in combat. But each of their backstories
are deep enough to be explored to a good extent.
Like the main character, Marcus has an heir
of mystery to him in the first game as to why
he’s locked up and what he did. Along with his
world views fundamentally contrasting different
characters. That and his strict and mean persona
has a fun dynamic with other characters who are
more lighthearted and fun. So from a world,
story, character, and action perspective,
this should be easily accomplishable with a good
budget that I hope Netflix commits to and actually
provides. Dave Bautista is practically begging
to be in the movie so please make that a reality.
Wolfenstein. Now for my last pick, there’s
quite a few games that I would love to see
like an Outlast horror movie, someone trying to
tackle the rich world of Half-life, or even a fun
blockbuster Call of Duty action movie, but for
the last game I’ll talk about is Wolfenstein.
And the reason why I’m choosing this game is that
I think this could be a very fun and over-the-top
action movie or show. Given that the games have so
many crazy enemies like oversized robotic panzer
hounds. Or colossal mechs that the Nazis somehow
made. It’s just such a batshit ridiculous concept
that you can’t help but love how creative and fun
it is. So the style of filmmaking that I would
absolutely love to see attached to the Wolfenstein
franchise is Bollywood filmmaking. This would make
a perfect pairing because the overexaggerated
aspects of action in those movies that clearly
don’t follow logic and are just there to emphasize
and elevate the action past reality, would mix
perfectly with the crazy world of Wolfenstein.
Like I don’t care make Blaskowicz a fucking
godlike entity in the game who can dual-wield
massive machine guns and solo the entire Nazi
army. If you purely go off the rails with the
action, then the fans would adore this project.
Now this story concept has been done before, but I
would love to see it done in this Bollywood action
style. I know I said in the beginning of the video
that gameplay-dominated games won’t make for great
adaptations, but I think Wolfenstein still has
a solid story. It fits in really well into the
story dynamic of an underdog and would make the
conflict that Blaskowicz has to overcome pretty
riveting. Along with their being some vibrant
and fun characters along the way. It’s not like
the games don’t have any story, because there’s
actually quite a bit of cinematic storytelling
within this series. This obviously wouldn’t rival
like The Last of Us for storytelling quality,
but the action is the true highlight here. Because
who wouldn’t love watching Nazis get obliterated
in the most insane ways possible. That would be
my dream from an action standpoint for this IP
and from there you could really do whatever
you want with the story and depart from the
games for all I care. The main game does have
a pretty iconic villain besides just Hitler,
but you can really make any villain within that
world iconic with creative and out-there designs.
So would anyone actually make this and would
this be a realistic dream? Probably not. I doubt
studios would actually have the balls to make
this, however, given that Twisted Metal didn’t
really take itself seriously and was a fun joyride
then this type of adaptation could be possible.
By the way, I have a Patreon and this video was
voted on by my patrons. So if you want to support
me check out the different tiers and the link
is in the description. Thank you for watching
and Let me know what video game adaptations
you’d want to see the most in the comments.